[SPEAKER_01]: Awesome, awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you, sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: You too.
[SPEAKER_08]: Solid waste issue did not pass.
[SPEAKER_08]: And it's not a fix, but it's a hold up.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's a reprieve for the moment.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yes, it's a reprieve, yes.
[SPEAKER_08]: I talked about it.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's where they're trying to take all the money.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_08]: So, at least for now.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know what they do for it.
[SPEAKER_04]: But that's the issue.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's not working.
[SPEAKER_08]: That's what I'm wondering.
[SPEAKER_08]: I do not know.
[SPEAKER_08]: When we have them.
[SPEAKER_08]: How in the world could they?
[SPEAKER_03]: When we have, of course.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_08]: Those electrical things or whatever.
[SPEAKER_08]: Everyone.
[SPEAKER_08]: And they, to me, and we're right, the field is right there.
[SPEAKER_08]: You know, so.
[SPEAKER_08]: And.
[SPEAKER_04]: Can I put them in the yard?
[SPEAKER_08]: Maybe.
[SPEAKER_08]: You could outside.
[SPEAKER_08]: You could outside if you have an electrical outlet.
[SPEAKER_04]: Run wires all around.
[SPEAKER_08]: You know, we built that house not long ago.
[SPEAKER_08]: We had one outside outlet.
[SPEAKER_08]: And it was on the deck.
[SPEAKER_08]: Well, we built a sunroof in there.
We have no idea.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you want to discuss a permit, you said?
[SPEAKER_07]: Got it.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's 7.
[SPEAKER_06]: I want to be here at 9.30.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, sir.
[SPEAKER_06]: All right.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll make sure to put you on for next Wednesday.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, of course.
[SPEAKER_06]: Thank you, Jesse.
[SPEAKER_06]: Have a good one.
Bye.
So I got, I did it for four 14th floor refunds.
[SPEAKER_06]: And they gave us... You want a copy of the front page?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, these two.
[SPEAKER_06]: What is it?
[SPEAKER_06]: What did they put?
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, the front page is for...
[SPEAKER_06]: But last one, I look at the last one, they've completely knocked off the point whatever.
[SPEAKER_06]: They only calculated it on this beginning part.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not recently, but in the last week when we got it.
[SPEAKER_06]: What was the time it would have been for?
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_06]: It would have been for October.
[SPEAKER_06]: October.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I just thought maybe we should call just to get the exact point.
[SPEAKER_06]: Maybe it's not all interesting.
[SPEAKER_06]: Maybe they knocked off this and...
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, they usually don't even look at that.
[SPEAKER_06]: This is what's just for my diesel.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's how I like this.
[SPEAKER_06]: Right.
[SPEAKER_06]: They calculated the diesel on the last one by just eliminating that point.
[SPEAKER_06]: So that might be why.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: And when did we get a check for me?
[SPEAKER_06]: 4-16-78.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: For November and December, we get 396-49.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, for both it's different?
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Hold on.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: Let's just make a copy.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Because I'm a little... Of the front page.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm telling you it's so good.
[SPEAKER_08]: She's so excited.
She looks excited.
[SPEAKER_08]: I didn't have my list to call.
[SPEAKER_08]: We're good to go.
[SPEAKER_08]: I'm here last.
And then just put it.
So the check that we got for November 4, 1678.
[SPEAKER_06]: Check we got for December 396, 41.
[SPEAKER_06]: Got it.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then do you want me to just download it?
I'll have to talk to the rest of you.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's part of the door artwork.
Twelve.
[SPEAKER_04]: I can't imagine they cost $7,300 just to make them big.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're going to have to look at that pretty hard.
[SPEAKER_04]: Send me the information on that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, documentation, where they come from, what the cost.
[SPEAKER_04]: Send that to me.
[SPEAKER_04]: Email address, commissioners.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think you probably have that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wake County commissioners.
[SPEAKER_04]: These are things that should have been done through at the time.
[SPEAKER_04]: But anyway, send me the information on that because I'm only one person out of three.
[SPEAKER_04]: The mirror part, you know, for replacing one with God, that should have been included in the first person.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right, right, Kenny.
[SPEAKER_08]: I like your headphones.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you have her email?
[SPEAKER_04]: You can get it off the website.
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay, it is a little after nine.
[SPEAKER_08]: Do we have a motion to call the meeting to order?
[SPEAKER_04]: I make a motion to call the meeting to order.
Second.
All those in favor?
Aye.
[SPEAKER_08]: We are in session.
[SPEAKER_08]: And we have, because yesterday, so shall we go ahead and do the pledge?
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_08]: And we will just avoid.
[SPEAKER_03]: one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay, and we are recording both audio and video.
[SPEAKER_08]: Do we have comments?
[SPEAKER_00]: Kurt Croy, so I was reading the
[SPEAKER_00]: follow-up report from the state auditor and he noted in there that there were 17 of 18 closed meetings that you guys have over the period of time that he was looking at that you guys discussed topics that are not allowed to be discussed in closed meetings so i was wondering if you guys are going to release
[SPEAKER_08]: contain discussion of topics that should have been discussed in open meetings I will just comment I thought what we went through with him it was more of we were on this topic that had these residual things that we sometimes went over to that but it was still the same topic but it wasn't covered under
[SPEAKER_08]: I'm not sure how we do that they basically said we just need to be aware of that and we need to stay focused on that and that was our plan to do
[SPEAKER_04]: moving forward in a different light and I think that's as far as we're going to go with that.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you're not going to release the minutes from this meeting?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to go back and readdress all of that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You said you've made changes to address that topic.
[SPEAKER_00]: In his report he said that the recommendations that the auditor made
[SPEAKER_00]: prior were only partially implemented, which in their grading or grading schedule implies that there are no further efforts being made.
[SPEAKER_00]: So can you clarify the change?
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't understand what you're saying.
[SPEAKER_04]: We haven't seen the report yet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Regarding the Sunshine Law recommendations from the prior audit, it says for the recommendations that they are partially implemented, and it defines that as the auditee implemented the recommendation in part but is not making efforts to fully implement it.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you just said that you are trying to make changes, I guess, so I wanted to get clarification on all of that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I guess we'll have to wait until we report and then make an interview.
[SPEAKER_08]: And that is what we want to do as we move forward.
[SPEAKER_08]: We are just going to be sure that we are staying focused on the topic under the statute and helping them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so the auditor's report is incorrect and you are trying to make changes?
[SPEAKER_08]: No, Curtis, it is not incorrect.
[SPEAKER_08]: The auditor's report is correct, and we are making every effort to follow their recommendations.
[SPEAKER_08]: So that's just what it is.
[SPEAKER_08]: okay i mean that's the opposite of what the report says those are contradictory claims you do you want to talk to the auditor and tell them they're being contradictory i mean they we have a great meeting with them we worked through everything and felt that it was a really really good meeting honestly they were fairly complimentary yes so and said this is an issue that is statewide it's hard when you go into a session
[SPEAKER_08]: that there's residual things that happen versus the topic that is covered by the statute.
[SPEAKER_08]: And, you know, it's the size county that we are, most counties, the larger counties, they have their attorneys sitting right there saying, you can't do that, you can't do this, you can't do that.
[SPEAKER_08]: We, none of us, are legal people and we are doing the best we can with how we can do it.
[SPEAKER_08]: We do not have that constant oversight to help us do that.
[SPEAKER_08]: So, doing the best we can and that's where we are.
[SPEAKER_08]: But no, we are not fighting with the auditor.
[SPEAKER_08]: We had a great meeting with them.
[SPEAKER_08]: You might want to fight with the auditor, but we do not.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just noting that his report says you're not making further changes to implement their recommendation.
[SPEAKER_04]: Like I said, we haven't read the report yet, and when we do, then we'll have more information.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just read the development part to you out loud.
[SPEAKER_08]: Do we have anything else under other comments?
Okay.
We are reviewing the minutes.
[SPEAKER_08]: Commissioner Hockenier is reviewing the minutes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Have you gotten through it?
[SPEAKER_08]: There's just a couple changes and it's just, it's a period and something that doesn't change the minutes at all.
[SPEAKER_08]: After he finishes, we will.
[SPEAKER_08]: I've marked them, it's just punctuation.
[SPEAKER_08]: So we can approve them with that change unless he finds something.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay, do we have a motion?
[SPEAKER_04]: We'll make a motion to accept the minutes.
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay, all those in favor?
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay, the minutes are approved.
[SPEAKER_08]: And we'll sign those free when we get those done.
[SPEAKER_07]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: On your rights.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm really excited about that.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: That would be fun.
[SPEAKER_07]: My dog, Mookie.
It would be good.
Oh, yeah?
That would be good.
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_08]: We do have to talk to them.
[SPEAKER_08]: I mean, they're not getting the bills to us.
[SPEAKER_08]: I mean, we pay bills every week.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is that what I need to do?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, that's the one that... Oh, that's the black one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: You sign that one?
[SPEAKER_08]: No, I was just seeing if you were checking.
[SPEAKER_03]: I got it.
[SPEAKER_08]: Keep this on my desk so I don't get to that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Pardon me?
[SPEAKER_04]: This is the one that they held because of this recycling.
[SPEAKER_08]: Helpfully, the discussion we had last week
[SPEAKER_08]: And then when you're ready for the diesel fuel.
[SPEAKER_08]: And I don't know if Melissa has anything for us.
[SPEAKER_08]: Sometimes she doesn't.
[SPEAKER_08]: It's okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: Do we know what it was last time?
[SPEAKER_07]: I guess I'm just curious.
[SPEAKER_07]: Each month's different.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's never the same.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm just wondering.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's a crisis.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_08]: I guess this is the number.
[SPEAKER_08]: I'm not saying why.
[SPEAKER_06]: These are all different amounts.
[SPEAKER_08]: And then all of these add up to this.
Just here, here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Crab, crab, crab.
[SPEAKER_08]: I go to Kansas City every day this week.
[SPEAKER_08]: So I cried, cried, cried.
[SPEAKER_08]: I had to wait less than 10 minutes coming home.
[SPEAKER_04]: They just want to block both ways at the same time.
[SPEAKER_08]: They want to keep us in town.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_08]: Did Ted have something to do with that?
Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: We finished that one.
[SPEAKER_07]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_08]: saw that the legislature is not going to go into a special session.
[SPEAKER_08]: The governor voted not to do that.
[SPEAKER_08]: The legislature was wanting them to pull back the gas tax.
[SPEAKER_08]: And he said that the state of the roads did not want to do it at this time.
[SPEAKER_07]: Thanks for keeping us on target.
[SPEAKER_08]: I'm working on it.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to keep asking.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, that's fine.
Are you hearing anything?
Okay.
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay, we have signed those.
[SPEAKER_08]: Do you want to come up?
[SPEAKER_08]: I think maybe we have a couple questions.
[SPEAKER_08]: This is for two weeks.
[SPEAKER_08]: So didn't you say that it was like $500 more each time?
[SPEAKER_08]: Each two weeks?
[SPEAKER_08]: No.
[SPEAKER_07]: $100 more.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: Because it's more.
[SPEAKER_07]: This is times 12.
[SPEAKER_07]: Versus this is times 26.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's times 26.
[SPEAKER_07]: Because there's 26 pick periods.
[SPEAKER_08]: So, just as you brought this back to us, we did review it, we looked at it, and made suggestions on it.
[SPEAKER_08]: I think Danny talked to you, and you added probably five different things that we thought we would like to include.
[SPEAKER_08]: One of them was bonding.
[SPEAKER_08]: That was one of the issues.
[SPEAKER_08]: And I think we...
[SPEAKER_04]: I make a motion to accept the janitorial services bid from Mike Kenney.
[SPEAKER_04]: I second it.
[SPEAKER_08]: All those in favor?
[SPEAKER_08]: Aye.
[SPEAKER_08]: That motion has been approved, so we're good.
[SPEAKER_08]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_08]: And we need to sign this.
[SPEAKER_07]: I love the claim the church does again.
[SPEAKER_07]: It doesn't remind you like when you're a kid running around.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think it's the Methodist.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't think it's the Methodist.
[SPEAKER_04]: The Methodist always did that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, it sounds like the Methodist.
[SPEAKER_07]: I don't think the first Baptist sounds like that.
[SPEAKER_07]: Ours is outside.
[SPEAKER_07]: Right.
[SPEAKER_08]: And then he's going to sign this.
[SPEAKER_08]: He's going to sign that, too, if you would do that.
[SPEAKER_08]: And then we'll make copies just when it starts.
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_08]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_08]: This is for you.
[SPEAKER_08]: I think Trina, maybe, I think I heard something.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah, she's out here.
[SPEAKER_04]: If he comes, we've got lots of questions for him.
[SPEAKER_08]: Don't you think?
[SPEAKER_08]: I'm here.
[SPEAKER_04]: What could we say if we didn't walk through?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because they never, they were sending this to the museum instead of here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the museum, for whatever reason, for the past year, has not gotten this up to us.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's why.
[SPEAKER_03]: Has it been changed?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're going to start sending it to me via email.
[SPEAKER_02]: I told them, I said, don't send it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Stop there.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know.
[SPEAKER_02]: So these are two separate, they look the same, but they're two separate invoices.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_08]: I figured there were some, and I said, we pay those too.
[SPEAKER_04]: You know, we pay them.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you would, give me copies of the bills.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't need to cover sheets.
[SPEAKER_04]: On these three.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_08]: Because we're going to meet at a certain point.
[SPEAKER_08]: I'm not sure if we set that up.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think we talked about it.
[SPEAKER_08]: I think we set that up, or we...
[SPEAKER_08]: Talk to him about it.
[SPEAKER_08]: We'll wait until Heather gets back because I think she's the one that contacted them for us.
[SPEAKER_08]: But we thought maybe a walkthrough would be a good idea to see what we really have.
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay, thank you.
[SPEAKER_08]: Well, we have to continue that when we get the cameras up out there.
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_08]: Do we know, and I'm going to beg you all about this, when you want to do the...
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay, okay, so just... Toby.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're not tabling it.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're not ignoring it, which is a lot of factor.
[SPEAKER_04]: Be sure to correct me if I'm wrong.
[SPEAKER_08]: I just didn't want it to fall under me.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, that's good.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think there's a lot of benefits to having everyone sit on what we're doing and think about it before we progress.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're kind of where we're at right now.
[SPEAKER_04]: Commissioner Davis has talked to a lot of them in the process since the last discussion.
[SPEAKER_08]: Marie, I just wanted to let you know, if I call in a frenzy needing something off my computer, I have a new password.
[SPEAKER_08]: And so sometimes you have to get in there.
[SPEAKER_08]: It was time to change it.
[SPEAKER_07]: Do you know if she has anything for us?
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm not sure.
[SPEAKER_08]: You know, something I was thinking about this morning, I didn't talk with the realtor that we had thought might look at the jail, the old jail, to see what we might do.
[SPEAKER_08]: person that was going to help her look at that that kind of test that's kind of this deal wasn't in last week so it's going to talk to him this week don't you think we should find out what do we pay for insurance on that building and right now
[SPEAKER_08]: tied to it that we pay for a year?
[SPEAKER_08]: Just curious.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, if it's costing us, how much is it costing us a year to have it and do nothing?
[SPEAKER_03]: Insurance.
[SPEAKER_08]: I just, you know, we say, how much is it worth?
[SPEAKER_08]: How much is it costing us?
[SPEAKER_08]: How much is it just for our thought processes?
[SPEAKER_08]: We try to figure out what we do with it.
[SPEAKER_08]: Do we have to have this much money for us to get it off of our rolls?
[SPEAKER_08]: Nobody knows how much it's worth.
[SPEAKER_08]: Every time we have a conversation,
[SPEAKER_08]: Nobody really has an idea.
[SPEAKER_08]: I'm just wondering how much it costs.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: She's supposed to call me.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's not a lot of money made, I don't think, on their end.
[SPEAKER_08]: You know, everyone would talk to about, can you tear it down?
[SPEAKER_08]: Well, the cost of that is exorbitant.
[SPEAKER_08]: So you pay some, you pay X amount, then you pay X amount for tearing it down, and then...
[SPEAKER_08]: I don't have proof on that, but I've been told.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yes, you're right.
[SPEAKER_04]: What did we sign this morning?
When is surgery?
Where are we headed?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he's out.
[SPEAKER_01]: I take him to the vet tomorrow for a follow-up and kind of see.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's getting around fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: He doesn't feel like he's in any pain or anything, but he just...
He loves dolls.
He loves dolls and stuffies.
[SPEAKER_01]: He loves dolls and stuffies.
Sorry, I got him out.
You're fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just want to put him in the truck all morning.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, how are you?
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you have the MTS original handrail bid plus the original concrete bid?
[SPEAKER_04]: If we're meeting with them this morning, I'd kind of acknowledge those as we're talking to them.
[SPEAKER_04]: to pretty much anything they've sent us in the last six months.
[SPEAKER_08]: Sit.
[SPEAKER_08]: Are you going to give me five?
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay.
Good dog.
Did you see the puppy?
She loves dolls.
She loves dolls and stuff.
[SPEAKER_08]: In the checking, we pay about $4,300 a year for the insurance.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah, our representative.
[SPEAKER_08]: I'm trying to think of a gentleman's name.
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay, well, anyway, that's for information purposes, so we'll think about that as we're trying to figure that one out.
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay, Tom, we're ready.
[SPEAKER_08]: You have some contracts for us that we have to sign.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, so the first one, this is for, which is in the budget, it's for the internet at the EOC.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we budget for it, budget for, you know, just to get that right.
Sorry I'm joking.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'm not joking.
[SPEAKER_04]: Carl Harper's office.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're paying $87 in local.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we don't need that.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we can cancel it because we're going to get the... Do we have that paper?
[SPEAKER_04]: We will.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I think cancel it if you can give us that.
[SPEAKER_04]: I didn't realize it would pay well.
[SPEAKER_01]: So should we purchase?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, there's probably a monthly service around the internet.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's another thing.
It doesn't show that on this.
I would mean that.
Yeah.
So.
[SPEAKER_08]: And didn't we include you in this discussion on the Kansas Phoenix?
[SPEAKER_08]: that we're going to, and maybe Heather was kind of running with that, that we were going to have a discussion.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know we're in a term of contract term, I just don't know what it is, but I would like to do it.
[SPEAKER_08]: And we did talk about, we think that we also should do a walkthrough to see, because when we did that,
[SPEAKER_08]: ones that we should know that they're being used.
It looks like you got it taken care of, Paula.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is, this is, will be, this is trained for the detention officers.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is Andre
[SPEAKER_01]: and it's
[SPEAKER_01]: following the NITO's accreditation standard that we're working towards.
[SPEAKER_01]: NITO puts this on and has this training platform.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we have nothing really now for them to go through.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so this is literally, from day one, like I said, all of the scheme, the staff will go through it as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: we'll go through this they have to test on it and then it actually gives them a path to get a certified
[SPEAKER_04]: Every episode is true.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, part of when I met with Munker, I'm glad I saw Munker.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jack.
[SPEAKER_01]: asking about how we could reduce the number of breaks for the sheriff's office.
[SPEAKER_01]: And one of them was documentation and accredited training that the counselor, all that shows, so that they can have it re-evaluated as far as whatever it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're also trying to find something like that on the patrol side of the house.
[SPEAKER_01]: He was very good about it.
[SPEAKER_08]: Well, since I've been here, that is the only contact.
[SPEAKER_08]: It was him that has reached out to us to try to look at options.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_08]: I appreciate it.
[SPEAKER_08]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: sign.
[SPEAKER_01]: I had you guys sign a contract to move our jail management system, our jail tracker, where we have control of the house.
[SPEAKER_01]: That has not gone very well.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so I think sort of God's timing of me being at the jail conference, and I met one of the owners of Cadence Software, who he is a jail administrator for Johns County, Missouri Sheriff's Office.
[SPEAKER_01]: He got very frustrated with
[SPEAKER_01]: I did the demo while we were down there and not only is it cheaper, but it's more intuitive because it's built from a jail administrator's lens.
[SPEAKER_01]: Went through the demo and it's incredible.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what I did while I was down there, talked with Andre and Sharon, like, hey, we can't move forward with Bomb and Go.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're not going to get there without them.
[SPEAKER_01]: They delay after delay after delay.
[SPEAKER_01]: The customization of reports, the things that we asked for that we needed to move forward with, they're dragging their feet at times.
[SPEAKER_01]: One hand's not talking to the other.
[SPEAKER_01]: We got an email saying, well, you're not even licensed for jail management.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can't move this project forward.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we're like, yeah, we already signed it and sent it back, and it's in place.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, it's just not making it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we talked to Clinton County Sheriff's Office.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's using cannabis.
[SPEAKER_01]: We talked while we were down there with a few other agencies that have already gone through the implementation of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: and have been really pleased with it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're moving forward and it's, Cadmus is able to meet our deadline in June 1st of cutting over to them.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's nice that we have a resource in Johnson County, Missouri, the chair's office that we've touched back and forth already and we're like, hey, we need this done.
[SPEAKER_01]: like a breath of fresh air out of the other.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what I what I did with the letter that I sent was, we haven't paid for the whole thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank goodness we you know, they do in stages.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we have made a couple of payments to them.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I asked for everything credit back.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're working on that.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that was around 13,000 a year, it's gonna be for the JMS.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a
[SPEAKER_01]: literally even without a manual or anything andre and i were able to go into their test notes and book an inmate from start to finish without any like no instructions that's just how much more intuitive but i think
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, the integrations where Omnigo is going to charge us for every single other software piece that we needed to integrate with is all included.
[SPEAKER_01]: We will be moving at some point.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're going to move everything to them.
[SPEAKER_01]: After I've seen the product, there are some
[SPEAKER_08]: As well as some financial gains.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, financial gains as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, so that's what that is.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I just need to initial or sign?
[SPEAKER_01]: Go ahead and sign on that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then I'll keep you updated as far as, I'm hoping we won't have to get legal involved and get the credit back from them.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, I don't anticipate that based on your email back.
[SPEAKER_01]: But yeah.
[SPEAKER_08]: And even if we didn't get that back, if it only went through a certain time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Worst case scenario, if they won't give us money, money back, I'll have an issue of credit, and we'll just stay on the patrol side longer, and we'll just use that credit for double mules on the patrol side.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're not losing it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's just, are they going to give it back to us directly, or are they going to do it as a credit is what I'm looking at.
[SPEAKER_04]: At some point, does this,
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, they have a patrol module.
[SPEAKER_01]: They have a lot more modules that we can implement and they're cheaper than what we're paying as well.
[SPEAKER_08]: And we're saving money, so that's a given.
[SPEAKER_01]: the other i think the only thing to vote on i was i was going to ask with andre and he'd be in a mindset now going to training in downtown having fires in the jail where they need to go purchase something i was going to ask if he could get a part as well
[SPEAKER_01]: Why does everybody have to have a card?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, because we're not always in the same place at the same time sometimes.
[SPEAKER_01]: We travel.
[SPEAKER_01]: I ran into the problem.
[SPEAKER_01]: The reason I'm asking is we get down to the jail conference.
[SPEAKER_01]: I put the room reservations on my card, and he got down there a couple hours before me, and he couldn't check in yet because he was on my card.
[SPEAKER_01]: So there's instances like that where I think
[SPEAKER_08]: But we do that, too, and we only have one card.
[SPEAKER_08]: And, I mean, we just say, okay, I'm going to check in for it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or there's times, you know, maybe on the weekend where he's up there at the jail or they come to run, they'll get something at the Walmart.
[SPEAKER_01]: We had to go and buy a microwave the other day, and I had tried the Walmart card, and it didn't work.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I had to get my personal card so they could buy a, you know,
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you know what was wrong with it?
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, it should be paid.
[SPEAKER_08]: I mean, we paid these bills weekly.
[SPEAKER_08]: I don't understand any of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just want to throw that out there and see what your answer is.
[SPEAKER_08]: You know, I will just say.
[SPEAKER_08]: We're probably pretty sensitive to that because at one point that was not a good thing.
[SPEAKER_08]: So we're just trying to...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, anything else?
[SPEAKER_01]: That is it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Easy peasy.
[SPEAKER_08]: I know we're going to do the walk-through.
[SPEAKER_07]: Did you find the information you wanted?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_08]: We're going to walk around the courthouse and look at that.
No, no one is in the room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_08]: and enjoy him.
[SPEAKER_08]: I don't want to talk very much about it because we're getting recorded, so I don't want to have names tied to it.
[SPEAKER_08]: Anyway, Hogan B., we have a card for him.
[SPEAKER_08]: And it was a personal incident.
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay, sounds good.
[SPEAKER_08]: That's very generous of you, for you and the property.
[SPEAKER_08]: How are you?
[SPEAKER_08]: Hi.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you have the key to the gardeners outside?
[SPEAKER_05]: Water?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: I got to wash out a unit outside.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, I asked that question the other day, and I didn't get an answer.
[SPEAKER_05]: Julie Towning said you had it, so...
[SPEAKER_08]: Is the walkthrough the last thing?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, yes, that's all we really have.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the answer is, I do not have any money left.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't think you have any money left.
[SPEAKER_05]: On your person.
[SPEAKER_08]: You all have a good day.
[SPEAKER_08]: I hope you do something fun.
[SPEAKER_08]: Just being with mom is fun, isn't it?